however if you ever play video games but
I play a lot of them and there's a
certain kind of ethos that's in a lot of
video games particularly those games
like Call of Duty in the first person
shooter games but it's important to pay
attention to because I feel like they
really hit the spirit of the age or even
games like Grand Theft Auto these are
big selling video game at me like that
block build beyonce's in those games
basically you're this fighter who
everyone has betrayed like the US
military betrays you your family betrays
you everyone is out to get you and even
your close military buddy or whoever the
story lines are always that ultimately
everyone's screwing you certainly it is
a safe position for a video game because
it's safe across the entire ideological
spectrum but I also think it pinpoints a
certain kind of mood of the era
anti-establishment runs deep across so
many currents you know and everyone's
got their idea who the big the man is
and you know you look at even like a
coca-cola ad and they'll encourage you
to go in your cubicle and throw out your
papers and get out there and just be
free so even like corporate America is
encouraging us to fight the man remember
those old ads and it was like the
dweebish pc computer guy and then the
mac guy was like was kind of Red Hot
Chili Peppers hipster kid he's like hey
you know and he's the individual its
freedom but I think even then even the
spirit of anti-establishment gets into
the establishment just to say because
even you know these big video games like
Call of Duty's in mega industries are
not like they're not like some scrappy
anti-establishment saying they've got
people that work on it the size of major
films like Jurassic Park big money but
everyone's anti-establishment and
certainly the mood in this country is
deeply anti-establishment
you
[Music]